le port d'armes je vous le répète
n'étaient pas liées à la sécurité du
président de la république mais à ma
sécurité personnelle pour être très
clair ce n'est pas pour sa sécurité
personnelle que le port d'armes lui a
été octroyé c'est dans le cadre de ses
missions de sa fonction de la mission
qu'on a considéré comme étant une
mission de police de coordination et du
fait qu'il est dans le cadre de ses
fonctions
donc c'est pas à titre personnel dans le
cas de ses fonctions manifestement
exposés à des risques d'agression que
c'est pas forcément mes fonctions de
collaborateurs du président n'a pu que
c'est qu'il y avait d'autres menaces
dans lequel je ne rentrerai pas dans le
détail mais c'est précisé sur cet arrêté
quand vous êtes dans des fonctions à la
présidence de la république ou pendant
la campagne présidentielle vous êtes
exposés vous même et on est tout sauf un
jeu qu'à moi de mon point de vue on est
exposé on passe dans les médias
vous êtes identifié quand vous habitez
dans le même endroit depuis huit ans il
peut vous arriver quelque chose donc
j'ai fait une demande pour ma sécurité
personnelle
moi j'ai fait le choix de conduire moi
même ma voiture et de me protéger moi
même parce que j'en avais les capacités
j'ai considéré là aussi dans ma
responsabilité de directeur de cabinet
en charge de la sécurité de chef de
l'état qu'il pouvait être utile dans ces
circonstances de déplacements privés qui
viennent dans l'entourage du président
la république
une personne qui est un port d'armes
mais qui est habilité à la boire qui à
la formation pour la voir c'est toujours
le gspr qui est en charge à ce que le
présent d'un public est en déplacement
je pense simplement je suppose que dans
certaines circonstances il était jugé
qu' il pouvait être utile que d'autres
puissent apporter leur concours
le port d'armes je vous le répète
n'étaient pas liées à la sécurité du
président
république mais à ma sécurité
personnelle il ya d'ailleurs une
curiosité à placer auprès du président
de la république quelqu'un de menacer si
on lui octroie un permis pour dames pour
sa sécurité personnelle et qu'il est à
côté du président est-ce qu'il
n'augmente pas le risque de sécurité au
soudan la personne du président c'est ça
ma question